після ви не заходу bespeco ви рядовому
кварталі криво заводу виступи
віце-президента з отриманих штатів у
українському парламенті кіка 100 мітингу
валики забрала собі листя верховного
раді за частини в майдан у джо байден вид
відео україни вже чотири рази кожному
разу за є що захир очакове ти
його без жвавої crockid
zara формування кошика тепер байден
ж прямо заявив парламенті світ це сизі
грам та українських олігархів
з процвітаючою і чи треба корупцію захід
більше не збирайся
окупалися сьогодні русі окупають
територію суверенної України
дозволь там і не сказати абсолютно читку
з отримали штати не ви знають і нікулін і
ви знають з пробу росія анексувала
крим ще одна крем того
висновки худої та імшу прохання історії чту
боротьбу проти корупції україна не може
дозволить і ще страв із нового витрачали
мадіїв
в 1 годину на заході означає
ідейки успіх та україни взялось а до
роботи антикорупційне бюро прибрано
антикорупційного прокурора у team,
руку в Україні не повернулася реально
кращих судових процесів на витіно
членами команди президента ці кільця
януковича
званого чаю на адресу 0 і har hil на
адреси корумпованих депутати
верховною радою шенол на кіфу ряду поки що
Місяць ці пари важливо збоку граматики
хактивістів теж відвідав за знала
представите німецького фонду фрідріха
наумана миріам космосі
поки і люди q3 пил нас теж від того
хто від рима відповіді не важливі і посади
дати думаю захист цього ти Петро їм за
дворика після майдану usb покращення
штати
чи треба Україні фінансово допомогу
трояндами і сам через 10 мільйонів
доларів зараз цьогорічного візиту
байден по вбивцях ще 190 мільйонів
доларів самий набір відпустки рубці ми
не поважають корупція пагорбу та рожевий
так україни там ще лікарі розходяться на
відомо куди те що ви знайдуть почав так
пісок так було за януковича і так
виходить
зберігається за схід тут вся
ситуація на забезпечену цьому че за
херня хоч і ви стирчать і простіше просто
ну викидай вчи їх пульт джо байден за
кліків українську владу порожньо в цій
національні інтереси вищі за свої
особливості
і ви колотий ви магніт їх хто за ними
цибулі або на майдані музику 2014